ah freedom of speech one of the building
blocks of the American Way of life the
freedom to say whatever you want no
matter how flopping and down with the
[ __ ] bein the freedom to say
whatever you want no matter how far it
could come up hate speech that terms so
hot right now
do I blame Donald Trump for using hate
speech during his campaign absolutely he
did it's a fact normalization of hate
speech speech two different things
I don't defend hate speech seems
everyone's talking about it but here's
the thing okay hate speech doesn't
actually exist now banning hate speech
would sound nice on its surface nobody
really wants to be hateful or
deliberately speak in a way that would
hatefully hurt somebody's feelings most
people don't but if you buy into the
concept of hate speech some questions
arise like who gets to decide what is
and isn't hate speech how much of hate
speech is protected under the First
Amendment if any at all what limitations
should there be on speech who are the
arbiters of this limitation on speech
and where does the idea of hate speech
let's start with this or political
correctness actually come from why does
it exist some will argue against this
but political correctness stems from
something called the Frankfurt School
and when you hear someone refer to the
Frankfurt School they're actually
talking about a group of scholars who
are associated with the Institute for
Social Research found in Frankfurt in
1923 when you hear the term cultural
Marxism this is where it comes from
political correctness and cultural
Marxism are one in the same but let me
read for you something that I think
perfectly crystallizes this from trench
Royer's critique of domination part two
27 as advanced industrial societies
developed the individual is more
integrated into and dependent upon the
collectivity and less able to utilize
society for active self-expression so
it's important to understand that the
idea of political correctness from its
inception was designed as a political
weapon to silence voices of dissent
which is why the new left in the 1970s
often used it and adopted it themselves
and that's why what's politically
correct is ever changing is it colored
people or people of color I don't know
what is it gay queer or fine no one
knows and this is why
correctness or cultural marxism and they
are synonymous lends itself so
fashionably to easy labels transphobic
homophobic xenophobic racist bigoted
Uncle Tom white privilige mansplaining
all of these are slapped on people with
politically incorrect opinions in an
attempt to silence you
was there a reverb on my mic no that's
MTV's decoded oh no that makes sense so
what does this mean more importantly
than making society less fun and comedy
suck ball or of a job or anything yet to
be defined
it creates an inability to criticize bad
ideas bad ideologies like Islam for
example or the current illegal
immigration problem or the welfare state
so hate speech is inextricably tied to
political correctness or cultural
Marxism and that creates intellectual
conformity or intellectual
authoritarianism and that's where you
start to see things like safe spaces or
trigger warnings or speakers banned from
campus or people with unpopular opinions
banned from social media and I know that
can seem trivial but today's social
media outrage can be tomorrow's laws and
as we've seen hate speech laws and
political correctness destroys lives as
we see all across Europe for example
these British men arrested for offensive
anti Islam comments these people
arrested for saying racist things on a
tram or our very own friend Tommy
Robinson who is charged with inciting
racial hatred with a flag that says
dices shouldn't other Muslims want to
Isis or this singer arrested for racism
after doing a cover of kung-fu fighting
at the wrong time because a Chinese
passerby happened to hear him outside
the bar means to go right
and if that's not enough just read this
list of 16 people who are banned from
the UK now that's not supposed to happen
stateside but it's often hard to defend
freedom of speech because you're often
forced to defend people who say horrible
things as you see with high profile
cases here and here and here now I think
what they're saying is terrible but
unless they're causing direct harm of
course their speech is protected in the
United States and our founders expressly
made that so my favorite here is from
Benjamin Franklin if all printers were
determined not to print anything until
they were sure it would offend nobody
there would be very little printed so
what's the end game here with hate
speech laws well a couple of things on
that front we have legal censorship from
the government and that's a problem but
it's not nearly as pervasive as the one
we face daily from cultural Marxism in
the intimidation the cultural
authoritarianism of intimidating people
into self-censorship sure the government
may not step in and tell you that you
can't say something but for fear of
losing your job for fear of being
ostracized in society for fear of being
exiled as a racist as a trans Fobo
labeled with one of these life-altering
names people are intimidated into
silence at that point the government is
not required which is the brilliant
sleight of hand that you see from the
modern left as seen here by the ACLU
where they will defend legally one's
right to freedom of speech but they will
hesitate at nothing to destroy someone's
life culturally for saying the wrong
thing I know a lot of people don't like
to acknowledge the spectrum of left
versus right but at a certain point you
do have to look at this you do have to
look at the First Amendment and say okay
Who am I linking arms with I get at
political platforms change but today
which side of the political spectrum is
always trying to ban speech which side
of the political spectrum is always
trying to create a new acronym for fear
of you losing your job which side of the
political spectrum is always trying to
ban people from campus from universities
from media from television which side of
the political spectrum is always
demanding safe spaces or trigger
warnings or creating post presidential
election council and because Donald
Trump won
[Applause]
on the contrast think of your professors
think of websites think of here on
YouTube which channels which outlets
which people on which side of the
political spectrum are always demanding
more open conversation are always saying
we believe a platform of more voices not
less are always wanting to have an
exchange of open ideas are always
wanting people to have the right to
speak freely even if we disagree with
them naturally it's the political right
which is ironic because if you want
progress in society well the most
progressive thing you can possibly do is
allow an open exchange of ideas and let
the cards fall where they may
if you've learned nothing else today
don't be fooled into allowing people to
separate hate speech and free speech
there is no difference there is no
delineation and as far as your right as
far as the first amendment does it
protect hate speech not only does it
protect it but that's exactly why it
exists subscribe how by clicking the
letters that say subscribe if you want
to read the references or learn more
click my face to go to my website or you
can watch one of these videos playing in
boxes next to me it's the magic of those
are boxes that are playing we used to
call them talkies